so you're trying to drill it just you're
not doing even I did you need me not
guess not the goal even I guess the best
so I need to do the drill inside the
vessel okay and you get into different
new kids provide different opportunities
they're all learning we gave you balls
are going to fall on their own stop stop
the Deaf technique let them follow their
own make a feel foolish okay
and then they owe you another rep they
have to do for if you can keep following
on their own you're gonna be there all
day okay and or teach them the hard way
that's still a body
it still has energy you can still
project it okay and you do the drill so
you never know what you're going to get
even in Kiyomasa
and even if you hold on them you never
know I'm not trying to kill him with my
arm but and a projection so the the
mercy is in how far my arm goes but here
[Music]
but he starts to fall over me you see
that so
I don't have to go fast insane hope you
drew and see the percussiveness
[Music]
why don't let hurt I don't take some
time close this is all like you come to
me you see they're all like counters
that people would do did you keep your
connection got it it's not Marshall when
you bust anything you're forcing in the
dojo not going to work against a
resisting opponent I don't know the
exact percentage if your technique is
not functioning below 10% of your
muscular output it's not working you're
just lying and then it's not very much a
spiritual training if you're just
practicing self-deception so you know
what you're doing you should stop it's
like when your product you you know you
know your notice it's gonna know don't
say the damn thing don't do that throw
just like they're gonna throw themselves
you owe me another one so what my tech
my technique has the projection what
it's ever met Scott to me
effortless okay
[Music]
oh you're faking it
where you going why you turning
[Music]
just finding it round
there's evidence it's a drill so project
what am i project you I'm always
projecting the center okay so I'm not
over here and I'm leading him didn't
take his head and the line and brought
me outside the basic but not in my drill
in my drill
I'm project his center in different
against two different things
this is why there's always and ichika
does a different rep every time so you
get to practice your g was inside your
key one was how my goal is to always
protect the center okay
so he he has a big bowl of harmonizing
union young
okay mine he tests he tends to do just
fine okay
so I get to do the full range of motion
so the last drill I didn't close it as
much so you can see that it's the center
[Music]
it doesn't matter where I touch how I
touch the center okay so you tend to
fall all right so she's falling on
herself
so her centers will just said just like
someone that's trying to count so I
still the throats going to be more down
do you think but I'm not gonna lean to
her
so am I gonna hear her head that's what
she was hey I just I still reject your
Center you see you see the difference
it's not gonna matter I'm not mom foster
it's just as you're changing that evil
I'm still staying with your Center okay
so here don't go here and let her fall
inside that little hole that she want
still rejected you see Christy ever
she's she's expecting to get up and take
it out cuz I stopped up Center slamming
her on that line would look like this
this is not what I did there's still a
percussion room you can see I'm still
doing them look this you can do she just
connects all gooshy in here you see okay
Jeff doesn't matter I'll find it on the
curb
it's still the same I still have that
Center and it's still working off the
ground laughter okay so don't lose it
[Applause]
[Music]
Wishart I got my ground vector look I
still have my job
see it's not a dichotomy between
mobility and stability because Brown
vectoring it's not bracing it's not a
widening of my basis of floor so I
realize it doesn't stop there's not
stuff there's not stuff
[Music]
okay so my two choices is not trying to
be authentic is if they're drawing
themselves site let them go
use some cultural shame on it okay or
you're gonna pay because I'm I'm gonna
still project you now on that angle you
tend to land flat okay help motivate
them use one fear to get them out of
another fear but you get to practice
still finding and staying connected
through to the dynamic center okay this
next one I still is too much like this
the reason that when they fall out I
still have the center and they can pay
the piper it's not because they were
falling it's because of what I was doing
okay
so I don't want you to understand your
team on it's just an external geometry
an external geometry that deconstructs
their line of gravity their base to
support their equilibrium that's not it
that's extremely not it okay so we know
we bought that kuzushi Panama I want a
better angle and then I'm going to cut
an X across the more severe you need a
Kazushi that isn't your agenda the more
muscle you need the more positives you
need the more severe you need that slant
the less it's going to work you're
asking too much of a aggressive
combative opponent okay but if I'm
projecting I can get just the tiny
that's enough that's enough because I'm
still touching this Center okay so we're
going to start short to me the angle see
how you drink that guy gives me small
angles it could be my that's it that was
it boom huge or just small outward
that's it into this alright so who can't
stop stop these extreme angles okay
let's go so because I'm projecting the
sinner I'm not leaning your mom not
doing that external face
okay so let's see let's move it let's
prepare okay and he's gonna block well
you see I still have this Center it's
still the same technique doing the same
thing okay you don't need to counter you
still have it you got it he's still
projecting to the center so I'm here I
do the movement until still do it this
is not his can I find this like I find
this Center from here I can find the
center from here and find the center
from here and I can find his Center
through there you got it
it doesn't change anything and I still
do the same throw so I don't leave it
here and then get his head I still have
to Center
my hands are still relaxed whoa all
still relax
still sing Kazushi powder